gut freunde der sonne kommen wir endlich
mal zu einem der am häufigsten
gestellten fragen in unseren kommentaren
nämlich wie schlimm ist süßstoff etwas
das super süß schmeckt aber null
kalorien hat ist manchen schon ein wenig
suspekt und dann hört man immer wieder
dass süßstoffe heißhunger übergewicht
diabetes typ 2 auslösen soll
also all das was man ja eben nicht
möchte wenn man zur cola light greift
sind aspartam sachalin und co wirklich
so schlimm wie kurze antwort ist ja und
nein und die lange antwort die gibt's
jetzt erstmal die basics süßstoffe
sollen ja zucker ersetzen denn eine
zuckerreiche ernährung erhöht das risiko
für übergewicht diabetes typ 2 und
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen aber zucker
ersetzen ist gar nicht so einfach
zunächst schmeckt uns zucker einfach
sehr gut und geschmack von süßstoff
kommt da einfach nicht ran lebensmittel
hersteller haben wenig anreize den
zuckergehalt zu senken zucker ist fast
überall zugesetzt als billiger
geschmacksverstärker außerdem hat zucker
neben der süße auch noch einige wichtige
physikalisch chemische eigenschaften für
lebensmittel bei eiscreme gilt zum
beispiel je weniger zucker desto härter
und cremiger das eis auch gebäck oder
kuchen wir trocken wenn man zucker
reduziert deshalb gibt es auch eine
ganze reihe an süßstoffen mit
verschiedenen süße geraten aber auch mit
verschiedenen physikalisch-chemischen
eigenschaften um nicht nur die süße des
zuckers sondern auch das gesamte haus
viel zu kompensieren immer so schön sagt
und gibt es immer wieder schlagzeilen
dass süßstoffe wie aspartam oder serien
beim menschen krebs auslösen können
doch für diese sorgen gibt es keine
belastbaren daten die sorgen beruht zwar
auf wissenschaftlicher forschung die
allerdings vorschnell interpretiert
wurde nach warnsignalen aus
tierversuchen oder einzelnen studien
stellten ausführliche studien keinen
zusammenhang zwischen süßstoffen und
krebs an menschen fest ok vor krebs muss
man bei süßstoffen also keine angst
haben aber die anderen sollen die
sollten wir jetzt mal etwas genauer
anschauen
doch dafür müssen wir erst mal verstehen
wie funktionieren sie stoffe sie stoffe
sind
die genau wie zuckermoleküle an die süss
rezeptoren auf unserer zunge binden und
dann das signal süß an unser gehirn
weiter geben da sie meist besonders
stark mit den rezeptoren wechselwirken
sind süßstoffe besonders süßer als
zucker
doch abgesehen von den süß rezeptoren
auf der zunge kann der rest des körpers
mit vielen süßstoffen nichts anfangen
denn sie werden nicht verstoffwechselt
man sagt sie sind ihm ehrt das bedeutet
sie beteiligen sich nicht an chemischen
reaktion
sie passieren unbeteiligt ihn ehrt den
körper wenn keine chemischen reaktionen
mit dem süßstoff molekül stattfinden
dann kann aus diesem molekül auch keine
energie gewonnen werden
deshalb haben süßstoffe wie aspartam
sakharin cyclamat sucralose auch keine
kalorien es gibt auch süßstoffe die
verstoffwechselt werden und damit auch
kalorien haben dazu zählen die zucker
alkohol also sorbit xylit malt it und so
weiter die werden zum beispiel in
zahnpflege counties eingesetzt doch es
geht hier nicht nur um kalorien sondern
auch darum wie unser körper direkt auf
zucker reagiert wann immer wir zucker
genauer gesagt luckow sie zu uns nehmen
geht diese glukose erstmal ins blut der
blutzucker steigt das erst mal nichts
schlimmes das passiert nach jedem essen
aber wenn der blutzuckerspiegel
dauerhaft erhöht bleibt jetzt ungesund
deshalb schüttet unser körper ein hormon
namens insulin aus insulin sorgt dafür
dass der blutzuckerspiegel wieder sinkt
je schlechter diese insulin antwort
funktioniert also je höher der
blutzuckerspiegel und je länger er
erhöht bleibt desto schlechter bei
schlechten blutzucker werden kann eine
sogenannte glukose intoleranz vorliegen
das heißt der körper kommt nicht so gut
mit dem zucker klar eine glukose
intoleranz erhöht das risiko diabetes
typ 2 zu entwickeln
bei diabetikern funktioniert diese
insulin antwort gar nicht mehr das heißt
sie müssen sich nach dem essen insulin
spritzen
um den blutzucker zu senken deshalb
werden süßstoffe geht den
blutzuckerspiegel nicht erhöhen nicht
nur diabetikern empfohlen sondern man
verspricht sich auch dass süßstoffe als
zuckerersatz das risiko verringern
können diabetes typ 2 zu entwickeln so
die theorie
doch dann schauen wir uns das mal
genauer an erhöhen süßstoffe die gefahr
für diabetes typ 2 und übergewicht
hierzu gibt es mehrere hinweise aus der
forschung
neben einigen versuchen mit ihren gab es
diese kleine aber sehr interessante
amerikanische studie 17 menschen mit
übergewicht namen hier theilmann gab
allen teil die man die gleiche menge
glukose um zu beobachten wie stark deren
blutzuckerspiegel stieg doch vor diesem
glukose zucker schub gab an den leuten
einmal wasser zu trinken und einmal
wasser + süßstoff plus zu klose und nach
süßstoff plus glukose war der
blutzuckerspiegel der teilnehmer höher
als nachts wasser + glukose und das ist
ziemlich ohne hört den eigentlich so
süßstoff ja unbeteiligten körper
passieren
doch anscheinend ist es doch nicht
dasselbe wie nur wasser also sehr
spannende ergebnisse aber die studie ist
so klein könnte man so eine studie nicht
in viel größerem maßstab über einen
langen zeitraum durchführen
das ist tatsächlich ein großes problem
von ernährungsforschung nämlich große
ernährungs studien mit menschen
scheitern an ethischen und oder
praktischen gründen
man kann nur schlecht kontrollieren was
menschen über einen langen zeitraum
genau essen
das geht zum beispiel werden menschen in
einem heim leben aber menschen die in
einem heim leben sind ja nicht
repräsentativ für die allgemeine
bevölkerung stattdessen kann man nur
beobachten
man kann sich große datensätze anschauen
und der frage nachgehen haben menschen
die oft süßstoff konsumieren auch
häufiger diabetes oder übergewicht und
die antwort ist ja
das finden sehr viele studien aber
vorsicht es kann zwar bedeutend dass
süßstoff zu übergewicht führt
es kann aber auch bedeuten dass menschen
mit übergewicht häufiger zur süßstoff
greifen was sogar sehr nahe dient ist
und dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für
diabetiker
deshalb ist bei der interpretation von
ernährungs studien egal zu welchem
lebensmittel immer vorsicht gefragt aber
gehen wir der sache mal weiter auf den
grund 2016 kam diese studie an
fruchtfliegen raus gab an diesen
fruchtfliegen ein paar tage lang den
süßstoff sucralose zeigen sie sich
anschließend hungrige sie konsumierten
vielen mehr kalorien als die kontroll
fliegen die zuvor normalen zucker bekam
darüber hinaus wurden sie hyperaktiver
und schliefen weniger auf das ganze auf
menschen übertragbar ist lässt sich
momentan noch nicht sagen aber diese
studie zeigt ganz deutlich ihn eher
unbeteiligt sind diese stoffe
offensichtlich nicht irgendwas machen
sie im körper nur was die antwort könnte
diese studie die forscher beobachteten
mäuse die entweder auf einer normalen
oder auf eine heidfeld ernährung waren
und sie versetzten das wasser der mäuse
entweder mit glukose oder mit glukose
plus süßstoff und zwar testeten sie
aspartam sakharin und sucralose und nach
elf wochen zeigten die mäuse mit
süßstoff eine erhöhte glukose intoleranz
doch das interessante kommt jetzt der
grund dafür liegt wahrscheinlich im
damentennis
dort leben nämlich genau wie in unserem
darm sehr viele kleine mikroorganismen
die darmflora oder auch das mikro die um
des darms genannt und während eine maus
oder ein mensch süßstoffe nicht an sich
verstoffwechselt springen die kleinen
herrschaften im darm durchaus darauf an
denn als die forscher den meisten
antibiotika gaben die darmbakterien
killen verschwand auch die glukose
intoleranz außerdem nahmen die forscher
ein bisschen mäuse kacke von den glukose
intoleranten mäusen und transferierten
die in sterile labormäuse sterile mäuse
sind so gezüchtet dass sie gar keine
darmbakterien haben und danach wurden
diese sterilen mäuse auch glukose
intoleranz
das bedeutet bei diesen mäusen führte
süßstoff zu einer veränderung der
darmflora und das zu schlechteren
blutzuckerwerten also zu einer
schlechteren glukose toleranz
tatsächlich weiß man schon länger die
darmflora eines
menschen ist sehr individuell also wie
sie besteht aus vielen verschiedenen
bakterienarten und die genaue
zusammensetzung hat großen einfluss auf
verdauung blutzucker insulin antwort wir
sogar appetit und fettspeicherung es
fehlen jetzt noch große studien mit
menschen aber die forscher mit den
mäusen von gradl haben eine kleine
vorstudie gemacht mit sieben gesunden
menschen
sie gaben diesen sieben
versuchsteilnehmern eine woche lang die
maximal empfohlene dosis sachalin und
nach einer woche 23 der teilnehmer kein
effekt vier der teilnehmer zeigten
ähnlich wie die mäuse eine
verschlechterte glukose toleranz wir
wissen aber sicher dass man
ernährungsstudie nie von tieren direkt
auf menschen übertragen kann
denn wir wissen sicher bei uns menschen
ist das ganze einfach komplizierte
einfach kompliziert labormäuse kann man
nicht nur gleich halten und ernähren
sondern sind auch genetisch gleich oder
sehr ähnlich
das ist sehr hilfreich wenn man ganz
grundlegende auswirkungen herausfinden
möchte zum beispiel was passiert wenn
man zucker durch süßstoff ersetzt doch
die nächste frage oder die für uns
relevante frage ist ja inwieweit wirkt
sich das auf unseren alltag aus denn bei
menschen bei verschiedenen menschen sind
die unterschiede in ernährung umwelt und
genetischen faktoren so groß dass so
eine frage wie süßstoff ja oder nein
nur ein faktor von so vielen ist und
dadurch automatisch weniger ins gewicht
fällt ins gewicht fällt hat in diesem
sexuellen paper wurden die bisherigen
studien zu süßstoff und darmflora noch
einmal neu bewertet und zusammengefasst
hier heißt es eine veränderung der
darmflora durch süßstoffe sieht man nur
bei süßstoff mengen die so groß sind
dass sie für uns menschen und unsere
ernährung nicht von bedeutung sind das
ist erstmal beruhigen
trotzdem kann man nicht ausschließen
dass auch sehr kleine aber dafür
langfristige veränderungen vielleicht
nicht doch kritisch sind
da bleibt uns derzeit nichts anderes
übrig als die forschung weiterhin
gespannt zu verfolgen ja und jetzt was
fange ich mir diesen infos an solange
die forschung noch nicht abgeschlossen
ist soll ich jetzt cola light trinken
oder nichts praxis sie stoffe ja oder
nein
ihr solltet es am besten so halten
süßes immer nur in maßen egal ob zucker
oder süßstoff dafür gibt es abgesehen
von dem gerade genannten hinweisen noch
drei weitere gute gründe erstens
freifahrtschein falle der glaubt dass er
sich mit einer cola light oder mit einem
zucker reduzierten pudding was gutes tut
der takt leicht in die psychologische
vater des freifahrtschein styles
geschmacks sind wir scheinen uns
geschmacklich an vieles zu gewinnen und
es gibt sehr viele persönliche
erfahrungsberichte die sagen je mehr
zucker oder süßstoff ich esse desto
weniger süß empfinde ich obst oder
andere gesunde zur quellen und menschen
die mal zucker reduzieren da gibt es ja
gerade auf youtube sehr viele selbst
experimente berichten alle das dann
irgendwann der standard schokoriegel aus
dem supermarkt zu süß schmeckt das heißt
wenn wir mit süßstoffen ständig unsere
süß rezeptoren überstrapazieren
dann könnten wir dadurch den geschmack
und die wertschätzung für gesundes süßes
essen verliert drittens wo sind die
nährstoff lebensmittel die stark gesüßt
sind und vor allem auch die gehe jetzt
mit zuckerersatz mit süßstoffen
angeboten werden sind meistens extrem
nährstoffarm ernährungstechnisch gesehen
völlig wertlos buchstäblich klassisches
beispiel sind die softdrinks wenn der
zucker drin ist sind das typische leere
kalorien so sagt man nur kalorien keine
nährstoffe um mit süßstoffen ist es da
nur ein leeres nichts
gesunde ernährung heißt gesunde
nährstoffe zu sich nehmen und die findet
man in solchen lebensmitteln nicht
wartet sie stoffe sind nach aktueller
datenlage nicht schlimmer als zucker sie
helfen bei der kalorien und zucker
reduktion auch wenn die nebenwirkungen
wie zb veränderung der darmflora immer
noch erforscht werden aber weniger
zucker definitiv gut die meisten von uns
ich auch sind weit entfernt von der
offiziellen empfehlung der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die sagt pro
tag bitte nicht mehr als 50 oder noch
besser 25 gramm zucker das ist gar nicht
mal so viel und süßstoffe können dabei
helfen aber wie gesagt doch besser ist
es ganz zu verzichten und statt der
kohle einfach ein glas wasser trinken
ja was mit euch nehmt ihr gerne mal
light produkte und seid ihr so richtige
zucker monster oder fällt es euch
relativ leicht zu verzichten schreibt es
in die kommentare
habt schöne feiertage und wir sehen uns
nächste woche bis dahin bleibt sicher